[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداثهم وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه بهذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس التي تعيش على اصداء
الهجوم العنصري الذي اودى بحياه ثلاثه
اشخاص من الجاليه الكرديه
من ابناء هذه الجاليه والشرطه
الان من بريطانيا بريطانيا التي تعيش
اضرابات تخيم على الاجواء مع قدوم موسم
الاعياد وهذه الصور من مدينه اوكسفورد
وفي مواضيع الحساد لهذه الليله
خفض انتاج النفط ووقف الامدادات لبعض
الدول خيارات تلوح بها موسكو ردا على
اعتماد الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع
سقفا لاسعار النفط الروسي
صادرات الطاقه بعيدا عن الدول التي
تلتزموا بالقرار الغربي واصوات من نفط
العالميه تسجل ارتفاعا في الاسعار
بعد زياره الرئيس الاوكراني لواشنطن
واعلان الدعم الامريكي لكيف بمنظومه
باتريوت تصاعد السجل الامريكي الروسي
موسكو تتحدث عن مخاطر انسداب متزايد مع
واشنطن وتتعهد باستهداف بطاريه باتريوس
وزنسكي يؤكد ضروره رفع قدراته اوكرانيا في
مجال السياسه الخارجيه والعمل على تحقيق
النصر في الحرب
من ابناء الجاليه الكرديه في باريس
[تصفيق]
احتجاجات ومواجهات بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين
بتوجهات العنصريه وانه كان يستهدف الاجانب
ووسائل والام تقول ان المتهمه سبق انهزم
مركزا للاجئين
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا معكم المواجهات التي حصلت
في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بين الشرطه
الفرنسيه وافراد من الجاليه الكرديه بعد
مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من ابناء هذه الجاليه في
حادثه اطلاق نار نفذه سته سنين بحسب
الشرطه وقد اعلن المدعي العام الفرنسيه
انه يحقق في وجود دوافع عنصريه لهذا
الهجوم بينما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام ان مطلق
النار سبق ان هاجم مخيما دلاجين العام
الماضي
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم قبل
قليل السؤال الثالث السؤال يقول هل
التعامل الامني والغربي مع هجمات اليمين
المتطرف كافن للحد منها
جاءت اجابتكم على النحو التالي صورت نحو
12% بالقول نعم هي كافيه في حين قال نحو
88 بالمئه لا هذا التعامل ليس كافيا هذا
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا كالعاده على منصات ان
الرقميه ويمكن دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقاءنا على منصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتترق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد هذه الليله
فرنسا وبريطانيا تواجهاني شبح الاضرابات
مع استقبال اعياد الميلاد
[موسيقى]
القانونيه التي ستطلب الامتثاله لسقف
الاسعار في العقود وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودوله مجموعه السبعه واستراليا
60 دولارا للبرميل الواحد بدا سريانه في
الخامس من هذا الشهر
تستمر الحرب على ملف الطاقه بين روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي سيالا وتبدو في ثناياها
مختلف الاستراتيجيات على اثر قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول مجموعه السبع واستراليا فرض
السقف 60 دولارا بسعر برميل النفط الروسي
بدايه الشهر الجاري لوحه موسكو بامكانيه
تخفيض انتاجها من النفط بما يتراوحو بين
75% في اوائل العام القادم
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي الكسندر نوفا
ستعيد عند اذن توجيهي الطاقه للاسواق
الاخرى وان الاولويه ستكون لدول اسيا
والمحيط الهادي وافريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه
وبجاني مركز توزيع الغاز الموزمعي انشاؤه
في تركيا نوه نوفاك الى امكانيه مشاركه
دول اخرى مصدره للغاز في المركز بجانب
روسيا مشيرا الى ان الغاز الروسي رخيص
الثمن ومطلوب في الاسواق حديث عن المركز
ياتي بعد ايامنا اتصال هاتفي للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مع نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتيل بحث الرئيس خلاله المصالح
المشتركه في مجال الطاقه ومقترح انشائي
مركز اقليمي لتصدير الغاز في اسطنبول
وكان الرئيس التركي قد استبق تلك
المحادثات الهاتفيه بلقاء الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه غاز بروم الروسيه اليكسيميلر
والتاكيد على ان تركيا وموسكو سيعملان
فورا على تنفيذي مقترح بوتن الخاص بالنقل
الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى القاره
الاوروبيه
الثابت الان بعد توقف امدادات الغاز
الروسي لاوروبا عبر انابيب نور ستريم واحد
ونور ستيام فان كميات اقل تصل عبر
الانابيب العاب راي الى القاره الاوروبيه
من اوكرانيا و بلغاريا وتقدر باقل من 10%
مما تستهلكه دول القاره
الاتحاد الاوروبي ينظر الطبعا بعين الريبه
بهذا التجارب الروس التركي ووصفه مفاوض
السياسي الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي جزء
بوريل عدم استعداد تركيا للانضمام الى
العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا بانه مدعاه
للقلق
وكان وزراء الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذه اتفقوا يوم الاثنين الماضي بشان تحديد
السقف باسعار الغاز الطبيعي عند 180 يورو
للميجاوات في الساعه وبموجي بقرار الاتحاد
فان السقف المحدد سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في
منتصف فبراير القادم
والان وبعد ان اعتبرت روسيا لاتفاق مرفودا
فانها قد تبدا في تنفيذ ما حذرت منه الغرب
حاله الاقتراب من اسعار غاز الطبيعي وهو
ما يوحي باستمرار الحرب على ملف الطاقه
حتى بعد انقضاء فصل الشتاء الحالي
معنا ايضا من برلين الدكتور توماس الخبير
في شؤون الطاقه
المدير العام السابق لشؤون توزيع الغاز في
شركه حكوميه تركيه اهلا بضيوفنا الثلاثه
نبدا من موسكو وسيد مشينكو عندما تلوح
موسكو بخفض انتاج النفط ووقف الامدادات
لبعض الدول التي ستلتزم بالسقف الذي حددته
الدول الغربيه
ما الذي تريده من وراي هذا التلوح
سعوديين
على الاسعار للبيع
اوه ديسمبر
تحت السقف
وبالتالي في روسيا عن ذلك ستكون عليها ان
تخفض التاجر هذا هو سبب
السلطات الروسيه هذا التخفيض في الانتاج
وامكانيه وقف الامدادات سيد اليونان في
برلين هل سيزيد
هل سيزيد من
صعوبه الموقف في اوروبا خاصه وان بلد مثل
المانيا مثلا همم الاستهلاك في الطاقه زاد
بنسبه 20% في هذه الفتره بسبب البروده
في الواقع
الضيف الروسي قال بين اسواق العالميه
للنفطه العمل الطالب
العالميه الثانيه الى
ذلك عندما قام بغزو اوكرانيا في 2000 2014
وبالتالي وحول موضوع مش خاصه السقف على
الاسعار هل اتسال عندما انظر البيانات
المتوفره مثلا من البلومبيرج نجد ان في
اسبوع اسبوع من ديسمبر بعد الفرع السقف
الاسعار الاوروبي وايضا العقوبات
الاوروبيه على النفط في الروسي
قدم من البحار من روسيا وبالتالي بعد ذلك
التصدير تصدير النفط
الروسي انخفض بحوالي 50% من الموانئ
الاوروبيه وبتسالي لان التسائل لان روسيا
حقا كما قال سيدنا
دفع ذلك طبعا لمنع الوصول النفط الى
الاسواق اما ان هذا
اصاب روسيا فعلا على كل وصفه هذا الجدل
الروسي الغربي تركيا سيد ده عارف اكتورك
تريد ان تحول
همم
البلاد الى همم مركز للغاز الدولي ارجو ان
تكون تستمع اليه لان الاشاره تفيد بانه
ليس لا يستمع بشكل جيد اذا ساعيد السؤال
سيد عارف اكتورك
تركيا تريد ان تحول البلد الى مركز
عالمي لتسويق الغاز الروسي في وسط هذه
الاجواء هل يمكن ان تنجح
20 سنه
تركيا
وفي شهر اغسطس كان هناك مؤتمر للطاقه في
موسكو وان السيد اعلن وقال باننا نقوم
بتاسيس مركز توزيع اللغات في تركيا
ازرق الذي ينقل حوالي
48 ام سي ام يوميا ويصل للسامسونج وسط
الغول والخطبان الاخران هم التوكس النورسي
واحد توكس اثنين واحد
اثنين ثلاثه طاقتين متشابهه وينقلنا حول
48 ام سي ام باليوم وان احد احد هذه
الانابيب وفقط الاحتياجات التركيه
فهو يمر بيعبروا تركيا ويصل الى بلغاريا
ويحول اللي ينطلق الغاز الى
صربيا وايضا هي مجاوره
اسمح لي بهذه المقاطعه يبدو ان الجانب
الاوروبي ليس مرتاحا تماما لمحاوله تركيا
ان تلعب هذا الدور كيف تتعامل انقره مع
هذا التحفظ او هذا الاستياء التركي الغربي
عفوا
همم اكيد في الواقع ما احاول ان نقوله هو
ان الامر يظل الطاقه اضافيه
يطلب خطين رابع وخامس لنقل الغاز ولا
اعتقد ان روسيا
قطرات الاضافيه
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
هذا الغاز تقول موسكو بانه رخيص ومطلوب في
الاسواق سيد ميشينكو في موسكو هل هذه
اشاره بان الطلب سيستمر رغم كل العقوبات
ميكروفون
العقوبات
في اي حرب اخر اما الطلب فهو الطلب طلب
قائمه موجود
الاتحاد
عن فرنسا
غاز الطبيعي لان لان هناك قويه
وبالتالي لان
واعتقد ان بالنسبه تركيا
امكانيه قويه جدا ان تصبح مركز
هي مزود الوحيد الغاز
سيكون دوليا وهل سياتي الغاز اليها من
العراق ومن اذربيجان
ومن مصادر اخرى مثل اسرائيل وبالتالي
اعتقد ان تركيا في موقع جيد جدا يصبح الان
تصبح مركز
لاوروبا ان تتعامل بشكل ايجابي مع تركيا
كم مركز دولي للغاز لانها في النهايه همم
ستكون مضطره لذلك
وانا وانا
واعيد السؤال مره اخرى سيد
روسيا وخاصه المانيا
الى
طلب كبير في اوروبا
في اوكرانيا وطالما ان هذه العلاقه
واستمر في ظل العدوان الروسي فلا تشتري
اوروبا
هناك فعلا حاليا
اندهش واستغرب لو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي او
الولايات المتحده لم يفضائي عقوبات على اي
مشروع جديد لمحاوله روسيا بناء انابيب
تصدير جديده الى تركيا والواقع هذه العمل
قضيه ضع فعلا العقوبات الموجوده حاليا
وهناك مصادر الغاز اخرى وظيفه في
محيط هناك طالب كبير وربما
الغاز عنها لكن في قطر ولايه متحده فاذا
استطعت ان تصمد حتى عام 26 و 27
[موسيقى]
هل الرئيس الاوكرانيه
رافعه وقدره بلاده الى مستوى جديد في
السياسه الخارجيه لمواجهه حالات الطوارئ
اوكرانيا في الخارج
24 ساعه في اليوم طوال السنه لا يحق لنا
الحصول على عطله نهايه الاسبوع وليس لدينا
الحق في الراحه والعطله وليس لدينا الحق
في يوم عمل مدته ثمان ساعات علينا جميعا
اننا ما اقل من العدو ونفكر اكثر منه و
نتواصل مع العالم بشكل افضل من الضروري
رفع قدره اوكرانيا الى مستوى جديد في
السياسه الخارجيه لحالات الطوارئ يجب ان
يشعر الجميع بوجودنا ويهتم بمساعدتنا
ونستعد الان لانشاء وكاله المعونه الدوليه
الاوكرانيه التي ستوسع جغرافيه نفوزنا
وتخلق خطوط اضافيه للتعاون مع الشركاء
هو في الجانب الروسيه حضر سفير موسكو لدى
واشنطن انا تولي انت نوف من ان مخاطر
الصدام بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
مرتفعه وقال ان تنوف ان العلاقات الروسيه
الامريكيه تشهد عصرا جليديا لكن واشنطن
تخشن قطاع العلاقات بشكل تام حسب قوله كما
اكد ان تنوف ان موسكو ابلغت واشنطن بان ان
انظمه باتريوت ستكون اهدافا مشروعه
للضربات في اوكرانيا معتبرا ان الزياره
ازيلالزكي الى الولايات المتحده اظهرت عدم
استعداد واشنطن وكييف للسلام وان هدفهما
الحرب وفق تعبير
نظام فتيات الذي وعدت واشنط بارسال الى
اوكرانيا يضاف الى انظمه اخرى للدفاع
الجوي قدمها بالفعل حلفاءه كيف الغربيون
وتؤمن هذه الانظمه المعقده مساعده حاسمه
في مواجهه الضربات الروسيه لكن التنسيق
بينها ليس بالامر السهل
منذ نوفمبر
الماضيين منظومات للدفاع الجوي وهي تنتظر
وصول المنظومه الامريكيه باتريت لكن الامر
لم يتوقف على الطلب من الامريكي فقط قدم
[موسيقى]
المانيا بالاضافه الى اب سايد 2000 من
ايطاليا ما يخلق دفاعا منوعا كما تريد كيف
لكن الامر ينعطف للتقييد اكثر من وجهه نظر
عسكريا ليس من السهل امتلاكم مجموعه
متنوعه من الامر في كل من هذه الانظمه
انطقها الخاص الى جانب احتياجات التدريبي
ومشاكل الامداد واداره مخزون الصواريخ
اذا وقد زار الرئيس الروسي بلادي بوتن
مصنع لانتاج الاسلحه في منطقه طولا
الروسيه تاتي هذه الزياره في اعقاب خطابا
القاه بوتن امام قاده الدفاعي في موسكو
قال فيه ان الجيش الروسي يجب ان يتعلم من
المشاكل التي عانى منها في اوكرانيا ويصلح
ذلك واحدا بمنح القوات المسلحه كل ما
تحتاجه لتحقيق اهداف العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا حسب تعبيرها
انضم الينا من عمان الان لفايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك حضره اللواء
عند الحديث الان عن امكانيه صدام مباشر
بين روسيا واشنطن هل هذا وارد عسكريا
حتى هذه اللحظه لا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
التحذيرات من خطر الانزلاق نحو مواجهه
والمواجهه يجب ان نضعها في مستويين هل هو
مواجهه على المستوى الادنى اي عن سبيل
المثال اختراق طائره لاجواء دوله من دول
الناتو سقوط صاروخ في همم في دوله من دول
النيته توجيه ضربه لشاحنه اسلحه ام نرتقي
الى المستوى الاعلى وهو الصراع النووي
ودخول الثالوث الاستراتيجي على الخط السقف
الاعلى
امر مقطوع به انه يصعب جدا او ينذر جدا ان
يحدث اما حدود خطا في المستوى الادنى قد
يحدث وقبل تقريبا اكثر من شهر عندما سقط
صاروخ داخل بولندا وتحدثنا ورشحنا ان يكون
صاروخ اس 300 سقط بالخطا وهذا ما الان رغم
التصعيد في الخطاب السياسي والعسكري لكن
هناك قنوات اتصال وهناك خط ساخن يجب ان
يبقى موجود وقائعم لماذا لانه لا يمكن
الوصول الى نتيجه ايجابيه من حدود في هذا
الصراع وبالتالي ستكون النتيجه خاسر خاسر
لا يوجد رابح في هذا الصراع حتى وان
ارتفعت نبره التصريحات من هذا الجانب او
من ذلك
التصريحات تصريحات بوتين بدات مستهينه
بنظام الفريق وكانت بانها ليست على كفاءه
كبيره وهي اقل من اس 300 تقنيه هل هذا
الكلام دقيق
لا يعني اقول ان اييي باتريوت باك 3 اتحدث
عن باتريوت النسخه المحدثه باك 3 اكثر
تطورا وفاعليه من صواريخ اس 300 حسب
المعلومات التي اطلعنا عليها واجرينا
مقارنه ما بين همم تلك المنظومتين ولكن هي
اقل كفاءه من اس 400 لماذا لان اس 400
تصميمه مختلف هنا اربعه 16 صاروخ على
المنصه تلك يوجد فيها كذلك 16 صاروخ لكن
الصواريخ هناك اربعه مدايات عندما اقول
اربعه صواريخ في الاس 400 اتحدث عن مسافه
400 كيلو متر 250 كيلو متر 150 كيلو متر
الى غير ذلك اذا بيننا هنا اتحدث عن
منظومه متماثله الصواريخ السته عشر صاروخ
هي نفس المواصفات نفس المدنيه ال-
المداليات ونفس التقنيات اذا هي تقع في
نقطه بين اس 3 واس 400 ولكن قطعا هي اكثر
كفاءه من اس 300 واعتقد ولا ولا احمل
الكلمات ان الرئيس بوتين كان يقصد اس 400
شكرا جزيلا لك همم فايز الدويري من عمان
[موسيقى]
وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان وزير
الخارجيه وان جي ابلغ نظيره الامريكيه
انطونيو بلانكين هاتفيا بضروره انتاج
الحوار في كافه المجالات وحل الخلافات عبر
مجموعات عمل مشتركه ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
من استمرار واشنطن في انتهاج سلوكها
القديم في التنمر احادي الجانب حسب تعبيره
كما حضر وينج لينكن من تجاوز خطوط الصين
الحمراء عبر ممارسه واستخدام سلسله من
الاجراءات الصغيره لتحقيق عمل او نتيجه
اكبر بكثير والتي من الصعب او من غير
القانوني تنفيذها دفعه واحده وكان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه قد قال في وقت سابق ان
الصين تهدف الى اعاده تشكيل النظام
العالمي وان واشنطن لديها استراتيجيه
لمواجهه لديها استراتيجيه لمواجهه ذلك
واشار بنكن في مؤتمر الصحفي الى وجوده
تنسيق مع بلاده لمنافسه الصين والدفاع عن
المصالح الامريكيه
راشد فوزان
روسيا تمثل تحديدا مباشره لنظام الدولي
الحر والمفتوح والصين هي منافسون الوحيد
الذي يهدف الي اعاده تشكيل النظام الدولي
ولديه القوه الاقتصاديه ودول ماسيه
والعسكريه والتكنولوجيا لتحقيق هذا الهدف
وضعت في مايو الماضي استراتيجيهنا لمواجهه
التحدي الذي تطرحه الصين والقائمه على
الاستثمار في قوتنا في الداخل والتنسيق مع
شركائنا ينافس الصين حتى نتمكن من الدفاع
عن مصالحنا وتحقيق رؤيتنا المستقبل وقد
ادت الدبلوماسيه دورا رئيسيا في تنفيذ تلك
الاستراتيجيه كما وضعنا نهجا ايجابيا من
اجل ان تكون من طاقه المحيطين الهندي
اه فاندام
اعلى نزل اليابان اليوم رفع زياده الانفاق
الدفاعي اكثر من 26% العمل المقبل في خطبه
هي الاكبر لها عسكريا منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وتصل زياده في ميزانيه الدفاع الى
رقم قياسي اكثر من 51 مليار دولار مما
سيسمح لتطوكيو بشراء صواريخ امريكيه السنه
من نوع كما هوك بقيمه مليار و600 مليون
دولار والتي ستمنح اليابان القدره على ضرب
اهداف على بعد اكثر من 1000 كلم
ينضم الينا من روما الدكتور
بجامعه بولونيا والخبير في الشؤون
الاسيويه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور مان هل هل
المشاغل الامريكيه من هذه المنطقه الصين
واليابان تزداد حده هذه الايام
يزداد
بين الولايات المتحده والصين يزداد ايضا
كل هذه الدول الثالثه
عظمه بينها وخاصه بعد
اجتماع مجموعه العشرين هذه الدول الثلاثه
والصين يرون هناك ضروره
التنافس ما بينهم ولذلك نرى بشكل متزايد
ان الصين وروسيا بجانب
ويضعون خطوط حمراء ما هي مصالحهم وهي
مسائلهم للدفاع عن مصالحهم وبالتالي هذا
قد يؤدي الى التوترات وايضا يمكن ان يؤدي
الى زياده التنافس ومحاولات ليضحك كل
الطرف ما هي مصالحهم مثل اللي شدنا ذلك من
جانب الصين وكذلك
اليابان ولايات المتحده لذلك على الارجاع
في المستقبل سنرجع نشهد بشكل متزايد
تصريحات مشابهه الاجراءات تشير الى حقيقه
ان هناك خطوط حمراء لا ينبغي التجاوزها
فمثلا في الاجتماع
المؤخرا ااه ذكر ذكر الرئيس الصيني كيف ان
تايوان هي خط احمر للصين في حين ان الوقف
المتحده وسط
النشاط
لتحديد من اين تقع الحدود بينهم وبالتالي
همم
سنرى ان هناك مخاطر متزايده وتصريحات
واجراءات المتزايده تشير الى او تبين
الاختلافات الكبيره موجوده بين هذه القوه
العظمى فيما هذه المنطقه هذه الخطوط
الحمراء هل يمكن لواشنطن ان تحترمها
تحترمها عفوا خاصه وان التصريحات بلينكن
تمشي بان واشنطن قلقه جدا
صعود وتنامي النفود الصيني
في هذه الحاله هناك اوضاع في نهايه المطاف
يكون
التوازن صعب جدا ومعقده في الوضع مثل
تايوان خير مثال على ذلك
ومن الصين واوضحت كيف ان ترى ان هناك
مشكله في حقيقه ان ناسف قامت زياره تايوان
وان اداره بعضل همم اخذ التزامها بامن
التعبان في حين ان الصين تعتبر همم جزء من
اراضيه او مشكلتها وكما هناك رجال مصلحه
مشتركه بين الطرفين ان لا يخلقه نزاعا
مفتوحه بينهما وبالتالي التوازن دقيق جدا
في هذه الحاله والتوازن هنا مؤقت اكثر
بشكل اكبر بسبب ان الحلفاء من جانبين همم
متضاربين فمثلا في حاله روسيا هناك حاله
انحياز واضح همم
ظهر عن طريق زياده الى بج مؤخرا وكما ان
هناك الضروره من جانب القوتين عظمتين
الولايات المتحده والصين ان يقوما ممارسه
نوع من ضبط النفس والسيطره على حلفائهما
وفمثلا الصين اكدت على كم انها تحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا على المدى المتوسط
وكيف ان هذا النزاع خلق مشاكل للصين حتى
لو ان الصين اجانب روسيا كما ان الولايات
المتحده على درجه من السيطره على كل
حلفائها وشركائها وهذا ينطبق على تايوان
في الولايات المتحده طبعا تريد ان ترى هو
مسالمه
في هذه المنطقه تايوان وان الوضع بدا
يتصاعد ما بين
الاستقلال لها التالي الجهد هو للمحافظه
على
توازن بين القوهتين شكرا
[موسيقى]
الان الى فرنسا مجددا والمواجهات التي
شهدتها العاصمه الفرنسيه اليوم بعد مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اخرين من ابناء
الجاليه الكرديه في اطلاق نار
وهو رجل
في الحادثه وحولت التحقيق الى شرطه مكافحه
الجرائم
بدات الاحداث عندما كسر اطلاق نار هدوء
الدائره العاشره في العاصمه باريس قبيل
وقت الظهيره وهي منطقه حيويه تجاريه
يقصدها بكثافه افراد الجاليه الكرديه في
فرنسا
المنفذ كما كشفت التحقيقات الاوليه فرنسي
في التاسعه والستون من العمر اطلق النار
داخل مركز ثقافي كردي وصالون لتصفيف الشعر
قتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصيب اخرون نقل لتلقي
العلاج الجاني وفق السلطات الفرنسيه ذو
سوابق في معادات المهاجرين فقد قالت
المدعيه العامه انه متهم بطعن شخصين على
الاقل بسكين في مخيم للمهاجرين في هجوم
وقع في شهر ديسمبر من السنه الماضيه على
عجل على وزير الداخليه جيرارد درمنا الى
باريس للوقوف على حيثيه الواقعه قادما من
شمال البلاد حيث كان في زياره عمل
اذا كان الجاني الذي اراد قتله هؤلاء
الاشخاص الثلاثه قد فعل ذلك تحديدا لانه
من الاكراد ومن الواضح انه اراد مهاجمه
الاجانب يجب ان نعرف من التحقيق القضائي
الذي يراسه المدعي العام هل ليتعلق الامر
بالاكراد بشكل خاص لكن في الوقت الحالي لا
يوجد عنصر يسمح لنا بتاكيد ذلك
لكن وجود وزير الداخليه في موقع الهجوم لم
يمر بسلام فقد تجمعت حشود من الجاليه
الكرديه حول طوق الامني الذي يحيط بالوزير
ما هي الا لحظات حتى اصطدم المحتجون
الاكراد بقوه الشرطه التي استخدمت الغاز
المسيله للدموع لتفريقهم بينما القى
المتظاهرون مقذوفات على رجال الشرطه
واحرقوا صناديق القمامه
[تصفيق]
تطور المشهد طوال الساعه اللاحقه حتى حل
الظلام وعلى وقع الصدمه قال افرد من
الجاليه الكرديه في باريس لوسائل الاعلام
ان الشرطه تحذرته مؤخرا من تهديدات لاهداف
كرديه وطالبوا بتحقيق العداله وانصافهم
جاءت حادثه الجمعه لتلقي مزيدا من الاضواء
على مشاعر الكراهيه المهاجرين في فرنسا
وهي التي كانت وقودا لحملات انتخابات
للمنتمين لاحزاب اقصى اليمين
[موسيقى]
معنى من باريس ان جودي تشيليا الخبيره في
الشؤون الامنيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد شيري
اليس غريبا نوعا ما بان شخصا بمثل هذا
الملف الجنائي يطلق سراحه ويصل الى ارتكاب
مرتكبها اليوم
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالارهاب لانه
الافراد الذين
حتى قبل موعد المقرر المسبق مسبقا لاطلاق
سراحهم وبالتالي نعم نعم هذا فعلا خطا من
حيث
العداله ولكن الوضع هذا الشخص خاصه لانه
شخص مسن همم يمكن كان لصالحه وخاصنا هو
يهتم بوالديه
وبالتالي لو كان هناك همم مشكله حقيقيه في
التاكد من هذا بارد
وقدراته هو وامكانيه يعني الاندماج في
المجتمع ولكن يعتقد ان التحقيقات التي
تجري حاليا ستسمح لنا ان نتاكد ونعرف لاي
اسباب ما هي الدوافع هذا الشخص التي دفعته
الى الى ليس فقط ان يقوم همم هذا العمل بل
ان يستهدف المجتمع الكردي بالذات نعم
الاكراد السيده
مستوانا جدا وغاضبون من عدم وصف هذه
الجريمه بانها جريمه ارهابيه علما ان في
احداث سابقه
المسؤولون الفرنسيون عاده ما يسارعون بوصف
هذه الجريمه بالارهابيه او العنصريه همم
عندما تتعلق بعربي او مسلم لماذا في هذه
المره هناك تردد في وصف ما جرى باوصاف
محدده
سي سي
هناك
من نوع من
المقارنات وقد حصل ذلك سابقا وانني اتفهم
تماما
افتقادك هذا فهو فعلا
فحقيقه ان ان
في الوقت الحالي
واختصاص بالمكافحه الارهاب لم يعرض عليه
الموضوع
وهناك معايير معينه لابد ان تتحقق لوصف
العمل بان وعمل ارابي من الواضح سيلفي
الموضوع
قد دخل الدوافع سياسي قد تكون قد دفعت او
او تكون هي
اسباب او الدواء هذا الشخص
لتوجيهي هذه الضربه الى هذه المجموعه
طبعا هناك في ال هناك
مسلمين او اجانب قاموا بالقيام بعمليه
اغتيال لكن المسؤولين عن مكافحه الاحرام
لم ااه لم لم يتولى امر هذا الامر لانه لم
يعتذر ذلك العمل عمل ارهابيا عملا اجراميه
اسمح لي بالمقاطعه وزير الداخليه وزير
الداخليه اليوم يقول لا يوجد ما يؤكد ان
الاكراد مستهدفين علينا ان ننتظر التح
عاده المسؤولون الفرنسيون لا يقولون في
احداث سابقه لا يوجد ما يؤكد ان هؤلاء
استهدفوا كذا وكذا علينا ان ننتظر التحقيق
لماذا هذه المره هناك نوع من الحذر لم
نجده في مناسبات سابقه هذا هو السؤال
بتولي الامر فهذا يعني ذلك
همم همم
مجموعه من الاكراد وكان احد شخص قتل فهذا
الهجوم همم
تاسست لهذا المكتب
[موسيقى]
التي جمعت
وجهت الاصابع الى تركيا وهمم
فحاليا عناصر التحقيق
اوبا ايه التابلوه
ما هي الدوافع
هذا الفرد هذا الشخص
واي التاثيرات التي وقعت تحتها ربما جرت
لها
وخداعه لا نعلم ولكن
[موسيقى]
شكرا
من باريس
[موسيقى]
استعانه المملكه المتحده بقوات الجيش
للقيام بعمل موظفي الجوازات في ثمانيه
مطارات مضرب عن العمل ويشهد البلد
واضرابات بالجمله وفي عده قطاعات احتجاجا
على غلاء المعيشه وللمطالبه برفع الاجور
عدو التضخم والاضرابات انتقلت الى فرنسا
التي شهدت بدورها اضرابات في رحلات
القطارات فائقه السرعه بسبب توقف السائقين
عن العمل خلافات بين نقابه السكاك
الحديديه والحكومه الاعياد والاضرابات
ثنائيه الوضع الحالي في اوروبا
زينه تصر الناظرين لكنه عيد على وقع
اضرابات وازمات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه تدعو
اوروبا العام بعلاقات مشحونه والصدميه
احيانا بين الحكومه والنقابات العماليه
حفله الاضرابات في بريطانيا بدات وستمر
حتى العام الجديد
للقيام بمهام موظفي مراقبه الجوازات في
مطارات المملكه ثمانيه مطارات في اضراب
شارك فيه الف عامل استنادا لنقابه الخدمات
العامه والتجاريه في يوم يتوقعوا فيه وصول
ربع مليون مسافر الى سته من المطارات
المشموله بالاضراب وصفه مسؤول النقابي
موظفي شرطه الحدود بالفقراء قال ان 40,000
منهم يستخدمون الطعام وخمسه واربعين الفا
يطالبون بتحسين الظروف العمل كان الاسبوع
الماضي حافلا بالتوقف العمل في عده قطاع
احتجاجا على رفض الحكومه زياده الاجور
تعاني بريطانيا ازمه غلاء معيشه ادت الى
ارتفاع التضخم بنحو 11 بالمئه وكان
المشاكل هنا لا تاتي فراده فقد اعلنت
الجمعيه الملكيه للتمريض عن اضراب القطاع
مجددا يومي 18 وال 19 من يناير العام
المقبل وكانت توقف سائقي سيارات الاسعاف
عن العمل خلال الاسبوع الماضي مقدمه لنفس
الخطوه في قطاع الصحه بمختلف اقسامه في
جدول غضب العمال اضرابات لعمال السكك
الحديديه وبعض عمال حافلات لندن
وحزين ويشعر بخيبته امل هكذا وصف رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك مشاعره تجاه
ما يجري في البلد قال ان التحدي
الاقتصاديه الاكبر الذي يواجهه الجميع هو
التضخم تضخم يقدم ان رواتب الجميع
[موسيقى]
فرنسا ثاني اكبر اقتصاد داخل البيت
الاوروبي ليست افضل حالا الرحله خلال فتره
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه لا سعيده ولا
ممتعه اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه قلب راسا
على عقب برنامج الرحلات وتحديدا عبر
القطارات فائقه السرعه تاثر من ذلك 100
الف مسافر بعد الغاء قطارين فائقين السرعه
من اصل خمسه تلبيه مطلب رفع الاجور قد لا
تكون ممكنه لان فرنسا ايضا تعاني من عدوى
التضخم والاسو يقول المسؤولون والمحللون
الاقتصاديون اسنادا لوزير الماليه
مستويات تضخم مرتفعه في شهور قليله
المقبله لا سيما في اسعار المواد الغذائيه
قبل ان يتراجع على الارجح في منتصف عام
انت ماشي من اقتصادي
اجتماعيه ومساعدات مستمره للحليب في
اوكرانيا هكذا تودع اوروبا عمل قاسيا
وستدخل اخره بتريكته الثقيله
والحديث عن هذه الاضطرابات التي تشهدها
بريطانيا وفرنسا وعواصم اوروبيه اخرى
الاساسيه هي مشكله التدخل وان حلها سيسهل
كل شيء منطقه اليورو شهدت ارتفاعا كبيرا
في هذه الظاهره الاقتصاديه وصلت اكثر من
10% وذلك خلال شهر اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي حيث ارتفعت اسعاره السلعه والخدمات
بشكل كبير جعل السيطره على التضخم امرا
صعبا براي الكثير من الخبراء بناخذ هنا
مثلا المانيا اذ يواجه اكبر واقتصادا في
اوروبا خطر الركود مع ارتفاع معدلات
التضخم وتراجعا في الطلب الخارجي وضعف في
سلاسل التوريد بسبب الحرب الروسيه وجائحه
كورونا والظروف الاقتصاديه العالميه التي
رافقتها فزادت فواتير الطاقه على
المستهلكنا ثلاثه اضعاف كما تراجعت مبيعات
داخل المانيا في النصف الاول من هذا العام
بنحو 9% وهي الاعلى منذ 30 عاما بسبب خفض
المستهلك الالماني لاستهلاكه واتباعه
سياسه التقشف تستورد المانيا 50% 50% من
حاجاتها من الغاز من روسيا لكن بسبب الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا الغي العدد من
الصناعات وذهب جزء كبير من ميزانيه
المانيا لتسريح الجيش ودعم اوكرانيا في
فرنسا كمثال اخر فرنسا فرنسا بلغ معدل
التضخم في اغسطس اب حوالي سبعه بالمئه اما
في ايطاليا ايطاليا بلغ التضخم فيها اكثر
من ثمانيه 100% في بريطانيا كذلك وصل معدل
التضخم الى اعلى مستوى له منذ عام 1982
ليصله نسبه اكثر من 10% في يوليو تموز
الماضي وفي اسباب ما تشهده القاره
الاوروبيه من ازمات اقتصاديه جعلتها على
مقربه من ركود اقتصاديا عميق نذكر اولا ما
خلفته جائتك لمده عامين حيث ارتفعت
الاسعار نتيجه بتعقيد سلاسل التوريد
العالميه حيث تركت مثلا المحاصيل تتعفن في
بعض الدول
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وما رافقها من
تقليص موسكو لشحنات الغازيه الى اوروبا
والعقوبات الغربيه المفروضه على روسيا
وهذا الامر ربما يعتبر العامل الاهم حيث
ارتفعت اسعار الطاقه بشكل كبير
ينضم الينا الان من بروكسل دانيال جروس
المستشار الاقتصادي السابق للاتحاد
الاوروبي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد جرس
هذا التضخم في اوروبا اين يمكن اين ان يصل
اغاني
مؤثرات بان التضخم في اوروبا قد وصل الى
ذروته فعلا وانه سيبدا بالخفاض ببطء خلال
السنه القادمه
والسبب ذلك من اسعار النفط لم تنخفض
واسعار الغاز بقيت مرتفعه جدا
ولكنها تبقى
شديد
وحيث انها
زياده في الاسعار
في بريطانيا او في فرنسا او غيره يشتكي من
هذا التضخم ويطالب برفع الاجور والحكومات
تبدو غير متجاوبه هل هي عاجزه عن حل هذا
المشكله
بالنسبه للعرب ليس هناك حل مشكله التضخم
ذلك ان الاوروبين
الذي يستوردونه
المجتمع تعمل
لا يمكن الحكومات الا ان تساعد بشكل جزيئي
موظفيها وعمالها لمواجهه هذه المشكله
الناجمه عن ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه لكن فقط
العاملين ويدين حياه افضل ولا كان اذا
الحكومات ليس لديها
الوسائل اللازمه للقيام ذلك
في بعض الدول ليس لها
غرامات
اذا قلنا ان اوروبا على ما يبدو تعاني
اكثر من روسيا بالعقبات هل هذا الكلام
دقيق
تعاني حقا من العقوبات لان اوروبا لم يكن
عليهم
وضح هل اوروبا تبدو تعاني اكثر من روسيا
التي عليها عقوبات هذا هو سؤالي
قله ال ال
الروسي وارتفاع اسعار اوروبا تعاني اكثر
من روسيا لكن هذا امر مؤقت فقط لاسعار
الغاز والنفط بدات انخفاض والسنه القادمه
اوروبا
صحيح هذه السنه الوضع لصالح روسيا
سيد جروس ان ان يقنع المواطن في اوروبا
بضروره الصبر قليلا لان الاعوام المقبله
ستكون افضل
ايقافين
يشهدون ذلك ببطء شهاده فعلا اسعار النفط
عندما دخلت البنزين قد انخفضت على الاقل
بشان بسيطه وان الفواتير الكهربائي والغاز
تزداد اقل ما كانت سابق وايضا بعد الثقه
بين المسلمين يكون افضل السنه القادمه لكن
ليس كلهم طبعا بعضهم من الافضل همم
كما هناك بعض الاوربيتين غير الصابرين لكن
الغالبيه الناس ما زالتمون بالصبر ويرونا
انه في نهايه المطاف اوروبيه صحيحه شكرا
[موسيقى]
الحفيد رقم
عاما اليوم عرف الرجل امه وابا والفضل
يعود لهذه المجموعه
[موسيقى]
1976 و 1983
من ما زال صغيرا منهم مستقبلا افضل نهايه
الحصاد هذه الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]